compared to 2002 men overall had the
same number of partners in 2013 but the
top 20 of men had a 25 increase in
sexual partners and the top 5 percent of
men had an even more dramatic 38
increase it really is that kind of
effective progeny towards the top that
the minority of men that the child are
actually cleaning up
a growing number of women are choosing
not to have kids and as a result are
advancing in their careers and using
their wealth to buy property and travel
more this is an article by bloomberg i
think came out of their business week
edition
ashley mararo isn't married and doesn't
have kids and she has a message for
women just like her you can still have
it all i love my life and feel very
fulfilled says mara who froze her eggs
in 2018 to keep her options open the 43
year old feels a deep sense of
satisfaction from her job as a sales
representative for a maker of medical
devices which brings her into contact
with patients and she relishes all of
the lifestyle and financial freedoms
that come with being a single child-free
woman in a well-paying job mararo who
was married for four years before
getting divorced in 2008 enjoys an
enviable degree of financial
independence the west village resident
owns her own apartment she bought in
2019 for around 900 000 and then
renovated and in june she closed on a
summer home in new jersey's long beach
island with a sister christina who's a
few years older and also single with no
kids ashley figures she's taken 10 trips
in the last 12 months and often friends
with a large group of about 25 people
who are largely unmarried and don't have
children those trips at 43
sound like they suck i do not want to go
on that trip
frankly
yeah so everything you just described
there is kind of like a a symptom of
what i would call the wider mating
crisis and it seems to be like a
cultural kind of prioritizing of the
male default of economic success the
kind of girl boss lean in kind of
culture seems to be set up as what uh
the vision for success for women
tends to be and yet you have a lot of
even corporate giants kind of getting in
on this um a few years ago you had
morgan stanley the investment bankers
put out a report that forecasts that 45
of prime working age women between the
ages of 25 and 44 will be single and
childless
by 2030 the largest share in history
and it's not entirely obvious to me that
this is in women's best interest i mean
i'm pretty libertarian in my
sensibilities about you know freedom of
choice for whatever someone wants to do
with their life and but it it seems to
me like a
you can see the kind of corporate
interest in
opening up more worker drones for 60
hour work weeks uh you know the
workplace now women are crushing it it's
a brain-based economy rather than a
brawn-based economy so
that that seems to be in their interests
and it's weird it's like it's almost
like huxley and it's like brave new
world have you read that chris yes yeah
so it's very huxley and it's like um
this kind of hedonistic life of going on
lots of trips having very atomized type
of sex single hood will be on the rise
you won't get attached to any one person
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
that that kind of thing and it seems a
little bit dystopian to me um to kind of
you know to hurtle towards that uh
dystopian vision but uh that that's the
the modern mating crisis we find
ourselves in and uh yeah that that's
where we are why do you think this male
default has come about because it's
something that i've noticed as well the
typically masculine traits or the ones
that would have been held by men the
conscientiousness the disagreeability
the casual sex the ability to move on
and not really catch feels and not be
emotional to focus on possessions and
drive fast cars
what what is it
that's causing that to be
imbibed by women and also pushed to them
by culture
so actually women are generally a bit
more conscientious than men um but yeah
i agree with you that it's kind of
flipping to that default and i think it
is just a
an organic backlash to kind of uh what
we might describe as the historic
oppression of women socioeconomically uh
you know it's kind of a leaning into
that freedom almost uh at too fast a
pace it's like one speed go foot to the
floor on girl boss mode and and you know
you have the corporate giants kind of
playing into that and uh yeah it's just
a kind of a a situation where for the
first time maybe in history men and
women aren't relying on each other as
obviously as uh in the past um
and uh yeah that it's kind of more
individualistic kind of uh world now
we're kind of uh
you know atomized and away from our kin
in big cities across the world uh which
is very evolutionarily novel and
so yeah i think it's just a an ordinary
uh somewhat expected backlash to maybe
the oppression of the past
like the
uh child of the christian parents that
moves out and immediately gets a nose
piercing in a bunch of tattoos and
swings back the other way okay
continuing on with that article single
women without kids had an average of 65
000 in wealth in 2019 compared with 57
000 for single child free men
single women without kids 65 000
57 000 for single child free men so we
already have something there that kind
of pushes back against the commonly held
uh world view uh the difference is for
single mothers the figure was only seven
thousand dollars parenthood was losing
its appeal even before covert 19 u.s
birth rates have been falling for the
past 30 years in 1990 there are around
71 births per year for every thousand
women aged 15 to 44 by 2019 that had
dropped to 58 so from 71 to 58 which is
a pretty big drop some women opting not
to have kids are enjoying an enviable
degree of financial freedom she's got
all of her different houses the
childless life does have its drawbacks
people who are single and child free pay
more in taxes and housing is a lot
harder to afford on one income than two
especially with home prices and rents at
record high and mortgage rates on the
rise so
that's the problem that bloomberg can
find with potentially going to your
grave with no one else that's part of
your genetic kin there to to see you is
the fact that you're going to pay more
in in taxes and housing is more
difficult to afford
yeah it's very corporate kind of
language isn't it that the main concern
would be how do we get around that that
one stumbling block of the taxes um but
i was glad that she did at least
highlight uh the idea of buying a house
on a single income because that's
something i always highlight for in
sales that that's a double whammy kind
of uh circular punishment it's hard to
get a house uh if you're
a single man on one income and a lot of
themselves are on lower income or no
income at all and you almost need to be
part of a jew learning household to get
a mortgage so without the house you
can't get the girlfriend without the
girlfriend you can't get the house so it
feels like a little bit of a circular
punishment for incels there and but yeah
that's a you can hear the corporate
language dripping in
in that account it's it really does rile
me up man the fact that women who choose
to be mothers are being seen as
second-class rubes that have been i
don't know
gazumped into taking a role that was
just some ancestral old version of what
womanhood was supposed to be you can go
out and be a boss [ __ ] you can get over
your last boyfriend by getting under
your next one like
all of this sort of rhetoric to me
doesn't sound massively empowering
louise perry's book case against the
sexual revolution is phenomenal at this
like loveless sex is not empowering and
teaching women that they should be able
to try and compete with men on having
loveless sex only one gender is going to
win that right it's not going to be the
women men are going to continue to run
through girls when they can and leave
them behind and
i don't know i just feel like there
needs to be the push back or the swing
back against
past
disadvantages that women have had
is not making women's lives any better i
think that you can comfortably say that
enabling women to earn more
in the workplace was fantastic the vote
the pill the washing machine all of this
stuff like things that genuinely
liberated women from the previous
constraints that they had were worthy
i struggle to see how encouraging women
to see the new pair of gucci shoes that
they've got that they buy from a job
that they hate to impress people that
they don't like
as being the highest point of
contribution of their life and that the
mothers are somehow second-class
citizens
yeah and it certainly is like it almost
seems like a concerted war on motherhood
even last week there was a an article or
over the weekend in the new york times
about the myth of the maternal instinct
and it talked about how uh you know this
this is a man-made phenomenon culturally
kind of a cultural script that we all
buy into and people were just
highlighting how ridiculous this is now
i think there might be a little bit of i
can give a little bit of a charitable
interpretation to that article uh in
that
the myth of maternal instinct isn't just
one thing so maternal instinct is
probably more accurate so maternal
instincts could sometimes depending on
the age of the woman
her marital situation or her
socioeconomic status that maternal
instinct might even be infanticide so
you know it's a it's a suite of
instincts that are kind of activated in
in different situations like all of our
evolved psychology it's not it's not
just on or off it's it's just in which
environment it comes
on play
as i said over dinner the other evening
that is
way
way too much of a charitable
interpretation that person that wrote
that article doesn't even know what
you're on about and you've extrapolated
out this it speaks to your good nature
um would you say women who can't find a
mate that they're attracted to are a
kind of insult
right so i get asked this all the time
it's funny when ever you pick a topic to
research like incels one of the first
questions is what about the femme cells
well for my study i could only find nine
femme cells i would like to maybe do
a femcel study one day and my thinking
on this has evolved somewhat initially i
would kind of agree with the incel line
that they would say there's no real such
thing as no such thing as a real fem
cell in the same way as an incel because
most women can go out and get sex or a
relationship if they want it might not
be the sex or love or relationship that
they want but they can get something and
for in cells i think this is a real
failure of cross-sex mind-reading
because for in cells they kind of look
at it in a very black and white
way and perhaps a lot of men generally
do this too that they think something is
better than nothing for men sex is like
pizza there's good pizza and there's
pizza there's no bad pizza really but
for women that's not the case and i
think we're underestimating just how
much women don't like having sex with
men they don't like having sex with it's
like repellent to them they have high
discussed sensitivity uh or low
they're like um
it's really repugnant that idea to have
to have sex with someone you don't want
and it's actually cost inflicting so
something is not better than uh than
nothing always for a woman and that's
kind of a failure of cross-sex
mind-reading i think on the behalf of
himself louise perry in her book she
talks about this
prostitute that was working on it i
think it's a prostitute rather than an
escort i don't know what the difference
is escort's just like nicer um but
and she said that one of the first
skills that you need to develop as a
prostitute is to not throw up when
you're having sex with a client because
you you are having to give yourself an
out of body experience to detach the
emotions from what's going on to you
physically yeah that actually i listened
to that and uh
that gave me an idea for a study because
there's another evolutionary
psychologist called hannah bradshaw and
at a recent conference she presented
something undiscussed that showed that
when you have control over your
environment then your your disgust is
quite high sensitive whereas if you
don't have control over your environment
you down regulate your disgust so take
for example the pig farmer we're a
family of pig farmers in my house and if
you're working on a pig farm you don't
really have much choice to leave so you
kind of get used to the smell whereas if
you visit a pig farm for the first time
you might be like oh god get me out of
here and the fact that you can get out
would maybe make you think oh okay i
gotta leave this disgust is high so i
think an idea for a study might be uh to
examine whether sex workers who have
more control over the clientele that
they see do they have a higher level of
sensitivity of disgust because they can
control it so they don't have to um
whereas those who are really like you
know a prostitute or a sex worker who
maybe doesn't have really that much
control they probably down regulate
their disgust mechanism kind of like
louise um talks about there
dude that's fascinating the pig farmer
theory of female sexual disgust my
father would be absolutely delighted if
i would hate farming into my theory
i can see him now i knew that all of
those those hours on the pig farm was
going to work out when it when it came
to your phd all right so just finishing
off that discussion about the lady the
boss [ __ ] like do you see it as women's
fault for having two high standards at
the moment
um
i kind of
i can't really i don't think that's um a
realistic kind of goal to say oh women
just lower your standards um you know if
i was a woman or my female friends i
don't expect them to lower their
standards i want them to find love and
something that will add to their life
but there's a really good book um by eli
finkel called the all or nothing
marriage and it talks about how we put
more and more we make marriage more
um it has to be everything
your spouse has to be uh your
best friend your sexual uh paramore
inspire you
contribute to everything everything all
in one
whereas in the past you might say okay
my spouse is a great
mother but my intellectual interests are
met for by other friends or something
like that that's no longer the case
we're putting more and more pressure on
uh what our spouse needs to do so uh you
know and that that that's actually it
means that
higher socioeconomic marriages actually
do better and it's the lower economic
ones that suffer which is a kind of a
sad finding um
so yeah i don't really expect women to
lower their standards and i don't think
that's realistic what i think might be
maybe realistic is that mate preferences
although they're evolved they're very
sensitive to status uh so you can assign
status to almost anything you had will
store on and he talked about the yams
the farmers who assign stages to whoever
can grow the biggest yam right so you
can assign status to almost anything so
maybe we could shift towards a world
where stay-at-home dads are more valued
in the mating market but
it seems to be a slow kind of shift
towards that because there was one study
that showed that just five percent of
women desired um a relationship where
they worked full-time uh and their
partner worked part-time or not at all
so
you know i always make the analogy a
woman can leave or a girl could leave
school and decide i'm going to be uh
either a full-time worker part-time
worker or stay-at-home mom whereas a man
doesn't really have that he has
obligation for success uh only one route
really uh if he wants to attract a mate
uh so that's i'm optimistic on one level
pessimistic on another um but yeah i
think rather than that you know what
what advice would i give a female friend
would i tell her to settle or would i
say no i mean you're you're doing pretty
good
on your own and it seems to be a veering
towards like that huxley and kind of
society of single hood as the default
is hypergamy on the decline
so there is some evidence uh for this um
which i think is kind of inevitable so
hypergamy is women's tendencies to mate
uh with an equal or higher status kind
of mate and i think it's inevitable as
more and more women become highly
educated and
killing it in the workplace that they
will begin to have to mate down and some
some evolutionary kind of based scholars
disagree with me on the fact that there
is amazing crisis at all and they point
to some of this evidence as evidence
that there is no mating crisis nothing
to worry about but even the authors of
that study that showed that hypergamy is
in decline said that they can't speak to
the perceived difficulty for women in
finding mates that they have to make
down with uh so it doesn't appear that
women are actually that what does that
mean
so
it doesn't appear that women are
actually that happy about having to make
down so
there's some evidence for this that uh
female infidelity is kind of on the rise
in lockstep with hypergamy so as
hypergamy is in decline
female infidelity not male uh goes up
male infidelity has remained pretty
stable over the last
50 or so years but female infidelity has
increased by 40 percent over the last
half century
and uh perhaps that just an artifact of
them occupying more high status
positions being around more high status
men
maybe increased anonymity with dating
apps and things like that lower partner
satisfaction as well probably
yeah no longer reliant uh on uh you know
no longer having to worry about what
would happen if they did get divorced uh
another uh troubling finding from this
um consequence of the decline in
hypergamy is that a recent study of 21
000 women in 27 eu countries found that
women who were higher educated are
earning more than their partners were
more likely to report all types of
intimate partner violence and that makes
sense from an evolutionary point of view
because men are most likely to kind of
inflict costs on their partner when they
feel like they might be about to lose
them so if their partner is earning more
than them and is around more high status
men
they're getting that cue and and they'll
they'll maybe shift to because when you
don't have much benefit to provide you
change to a cost inflicting uh mate
retention strategy so that might be
what's happening there so it's not like
oh hypergamy's in decline
that's nothing to worry about you know
there's downstream consequences of this
and uh
you know the mating crisis overall has a
broader con consequences too because
you might have heard of something called
young male syndrome chris have you heard
of that that's the proliferation of
childless partnerless men roaming the
streets in gangs and graffitiing
everywhere and kicking grannies and
stuff right so if you have a surplus
population of unpartnered young men in
any society cross-culturally
cross-historically they've always been
extremely disruptive and you know due to
elevated risk-taking and status driving
kind of behaviors and so you know that
that
this kind of mating crisis is dangerous
on a bigger level because that's uh what
we're leaning towards and actually you
know we would actually although there is
a level of threat from in-cell violence
i feel like it's over
overemphasized in the media and a bit
alarmist
but theoretically we should expect that
incels represent a very dangerous
portion of society but what might be
happening there is that their status
driving mechanisms are maybe hijacked
just by online worlds and their status
driving in forums or [ __ ] posting on the
internet and getting kind of counterfeit
fitness cues from pornography that
you're an evolutionary success if you
stay at home jerking off to uh the
stimul the stimulus of uh the sex on the
screen that's an idea put forward in a
great article by diana fleischmann
called uncanny vulvas
a player on
the uncanny valley uh it's a really good
read yeah so what you're saying is that
the young male syndrome which is this
phenomenon where a lot of
men without partners tends to be
destabilizing for society could perhaps
be being dampened down by
online status by porn all of these
things that are kind of simulacrums of
cues that they would have previously
been super aggressive about but they're
kind of being sedated into a more
uh
domiciled version of this right yeah
it's like a pacifier pacifying effect
that uh but yeah you mentioned there
you had joe henrik on the podcast before
right indeed yeah so he he wrote a great
paper called the puzzle of monogamous
marriage and he talks about how
cultures that began to practice monogamy
flourished more than those that stuck
with polygeny which eighty-three percent
of human societies that there ever has
been or have ever been studied have been
preferentially pollutionist and uh
joe henrich talks about it as in
monogamy's main cultural advantage is
the egalitarian distribution of women
and that that's a lot of listeners might
get uh get mad at me talking about women
as a resource but they're a reproductive
sexual reproductive sexual distribution
strategy man like if if man number one
gets woman number one to number 10 and
then man number two takes woman number
11 to 20 after a while you can see how
you capture a lot of the market where a
visit one to one two to two three two
three four to four all the way along it
keeps more people more happy and
yeah going back to what you said before
about how um
cultural preferences mediate sexual
desire or mediate mating preferences
right like what's held up in the culture
or something you could see disney movies
almost as reinforcing this back in the
day you know you find the true love you
go through challenges there are things
that try to tempt you away and so on and
so forth to see it as to simply call
disney movies a patriarchal
presupposition cis heteronormatively
telling women about how they're supposed
to stay under the boot of men you go
a lot of what was happening with
constraining sexual desire previously
and having one man to one woman wasn't
just constraining female sexual desire
it was constraining male sexual desire
as well it was making sure that men
reached the threshold that they needed
to in order to be worthy of having a
woman if a woman gives away sex too
freely men will meet that criteria and
if the criteria in the bar is set
unbelievably low men will do what's
asked of them which is not very much
yeah and you touched on something there
about the kind of motivational messages
of i think that's very motivational for
men the idea of uh you know
i liken it to football or soccer get the
goal get the girl that's the dream roy
of the rovers stuff you win the fa cup
and you get the girl with it that's very
motivational for men and it's kind of
kept men maniacally striving for success
for a long long time and you know i
always joke with my female friends
if you don't like male behavior change
the reward system start rewarding
different things and we'll follow suit
you know yeah are the rules of the game
yeah yeah exactly so that the idea of uh
but there's become a cultural trend to
kind of take to maybe frame it as
misogynistic for men to view
self-development uh as if as attached to
getting a girl right so i always tell
the story about barack obama a couple of
years ago wrote his autobiography and he
got in wild trouble because in a couple
of chapters he talked about when he was
at college he started reading different
types of literature to impress specific
different girls he was like oh the girl
in my sociology class who loved marx i
made sure to read everything i could on
marx just to impress her and everyone
thought oh this is really almost
misogynistic or manipulative which is uh
strange because it's like you know
that's very intuitive to men to kind of
self-develop with the goal
of getting the girl and you can see how
maybe uh you know red pill circles or
pick-up artists kind of those
communities can descend into maybe some
toxicity or manipulation kind of you can
see how maybe they go over the line but
i really hold
i'm still optimistic that there is space
and need for an ethical pick-up artistry
yeah
holistic men's self-improvement i think
is
completely needed hamza who's a good
buddy of mine he's really pushing toward
that on youtube at the moment i think
that mate by jeffrey miller and tucker
max was a really good attempt at doing
that for any of the guys that are
wanting to learn a little bit more about
this or girls as well a fascinating read
for everybody this book that is written
by
basically a professional [ __ ] boy for a
decade and an evolutionary psychologist
if if your current boss david boss is
the granddaddy then jeffrey's probably
one of the fathers and they put this
book together and they spend
chapters
explaining to men what it feels like to
be a woman in the dating market because
perhaps unsurprisingly if you want to be
a successful guy in the dating market
maybe you should spend a nanosecond
considering about the target market that
you're aiming for whereas when you talk
to or when you hear a lot of red pill
stuff especially kind of this new wave
that's online at the moment
it's all about how women have got their
sights set too high they need to bring
down their standards you're actually a
five and you think that you're an eight
and you're just an alpha widow and you
know it's very much about lambasting
women and very little of it is about
trying to understand why it is that
women feel that way it's criticism of
hypergamy tell you what no one ever
criticizes in the red pill space they'll
say that men aren't getting partners
because women are setting their sights
too high and they're not keeping their
hypergamous nature under wraps
they never say to men as one of the
strategies is to date older
right yeah
absolutely yeah it's very well it it's
very tribal the whole the whole culture
war in that in that corner of the
culture war is very tribal and i always
kind of get annoyed at it that these
concerted efforts to make men and women
adversarial and enemy 100 enemies
because evolutionarily we're not
actually enemies we're each other's
greatest ally and i always think that
these conservative efforts are
ultimately doomed to fail in the face of
150 000 years worth of uh selection
pressure is causing us to love each
other so we we're gon we're not gonna
stop loving each other so i i i feel
good when i remind myself of that
it's interesting you should bring up
tucker max and i did my undergraduate
degree in english and uh before i'd ever
even heard of evolutionary psychology
and a strange kind of segue was that i
did my dissertation in english defending
the literature literary genre of fratire
popularized by tucker max and he went on
to host the mating grounds with uh with
jeffrey miller and it was in my final
year of my english degree for an erotic
writing module of all things uh that
work is not published but don't don't go
looking for william costello erotica
it's not out there but it led me to
discover the evolution of desire by
david buss whose lab i'm in right now
and uh so it's all all kind of weird
segways towards evolutionary psychology
and evolutionary psychology is
it we call it the acidic idea the
philosopher daniel dennett calls it the
acidic idea that once you see it it
permeates everything uh and that's kind
of how it you kind of describe it as
lifting the the lid on the the firmware
or under the hood yes so yeah that's
very much it feels like going through
life with a bit of a cheat code of
analyzing behavior which is uh yeah i
love it more and more every day i feel
very lucky to have found a field that i
love me too i had a conversation with
someone yesterday and she said
the more that i learn about evolutionary
psychology the less that i can see
people as people does it get any easier
and i tweeted this to jeffrey miller
ages ago because i basically found and
i've been putting a lot of eve psych
stuff out on the channel and maybe some
of the audience of
feeling the same like the the deep
throated red pill is stuck in their
throat a little bit um
and i tweeted jeffrey and i was like
look dude i am seeing people less and
less as
agents of their own behavior and that
the
more just at the mercy of the confused
chemical signals of their body and it
kind of creates a little bit of distance
and it's fascinating but it's kind of
analytical in a way that removes
presence sometimes um does it ever get
any easier and he said it gets a lot
harder before it gets any easier but the
only way out is through
oh man the hero's journey
so cool go to the cave rescue your
father i love it read go to the cave
read the evolution of desire okay so you
shared yesterday on twitter a graph of
leonardo dicaprio's age and his
girlfriend's ages it went viral on the
data his beautiful subreddit can you
explain
what that graph shows please
yeah so hopefully you'll be able to put
it on the screen but it basically shows
like as
leonardo's age goes up linearly uh the
age of his mates stays roughly the same
at about 25 it was down at around 18 19
when he's a little bit younger but it
seems to be
25 that is his cutoff point for the last
maybe nine or ten girlfriends it's been
a consistent package reached 25 and then
he replaces them with another one yeah
and it's what it sparked some wild
discourse you know uh online and it's
revealed a lot of kind of intrasexual
competition and stuff like that so you
have some women talking about oh saying
oh he's such a creep you know he's old
enough to be their father which i think
is interesting whenever um women or
people criticize a big age gap
relationship what they do is they
leverage our incest disgust by saying
things like he's old enough to be her
father and
you know it's not related there's no
genetic link at all it's not disgusting
on that level but they'll they leverage
that our intuitive feeling of incest
discussed um but
and another comment i saw on this um uh
leo age gap thing is oh it's such a sign
that he's immature and not able to
attract women his own age and any guy
who does that is such a creep and that's
just so purely intrasexual competition
like of course women over the age of 30
would still be interested in leonardo
dicaprio like that is no mystery it's
not exactly horrible for these women to
be dating
handsome mega millionaire movie star
leonardo dicaprio it's not hell right
and another interesting take i saw on it
which was a weird twist um
is someone said i think it's actually
kind of nice that he knows he can't go
beyond 25 with a woman and he's always
but at least he's not taking away her
fertile years she still has a chance to
recover it it would be worse if he
pushed it all the way to 30 and then
just
cut and left which you can kind of say i
don't know how intentional that is that
might be a charitable interpretation of
yes leon's behavior but um but yeah but
it's a like i i put it up uh put up the
graph and said oh if only we had a grand
meta theory of human psychology and
human nature to explain leonardo
dicaprio's preference for beautiful
fertile young women you know
yeah people people getting very very
excited about this craft
the interesting thing is i didn't see
any of the girls talk about this online
but
it has to be a signal in the same way as
one of the best ways to be attractive as
a man is to walk into the club with a
couple of girls on your arm that are
both attractive and seem to give you
attention
it has to be the case that somewhere
deep in the programming of some women
they look at the fact that leo is able
to date a woman that's half his age and
think
he's getting something right there
now this is not the sort of thing that
would be very
popular to post about online the fact
that you use the mate value of a man
as a proxy for the man's mate value
himself especially as he gets older
which is something that is like
completely um
irreversible right there's no there's
nothing you can do about that you can't
you can't lift your way out of being 53.
yeah absolutely and like they've done a
lot of studies that show that mate value
or your sense of your own mate value is
a direct proxy for self-esteem
particularly for men so uh yeah i
wouldn't be surprised that and a lot of
women in their mate preferences uh
engage in mid copying so make uh made
choice copying so if one woman kind of
it's like fashion almost if one woman
endorses a guy he suddenly becomes oh
well he must be uh he must be all right
someone vetted him you know the example
i i'll use there is what's his name phil
davison or pete davison he's suddenly
able to pull every smoking hot woman in
hollywood like all of a sudden and it
snowballs and you might even notice
chris in your own life that sometimes
when you have a girlfriend you seem to
get a bit more attention and i don't
know from other women and i don't know
whether it's because you're more relaxed
and your guard is a bit more down but
some of it might be
oh yeah someone has considered him high
value enough but so the commentator who
put up about leo she actually made the
opposite argument and she said oh i find
it so hot when a man is dating an older
woman who is um like very sophisticated
because it signals he's obviously smart
whereas if he goes for the fertile young
woman it signals that he's
he's not able to keep up with the
intellectual yeah
i've got the tweet i've got the tweet
here the whole dicaprio thing reminds me
one reason a guy might constantly choose
much younger partners is because women
his own age have higher standards from
an adult woman's point of view when we
see a man with a woman more or less his
age or older we know that guy is most
likely great macron is probably the most
extreme we know of every time i look at
that guy i'm thinking oh my god he must
be [ __ ] smart if that woman who could
have picked from a 40-year age range
thinks that he's the partner
that could not be more backwards that
literally could not be more backward how
are you going to try and tell me that a
woman that's 53
is
higher he's going to have higher
standards than a woman that is slap bang
in the middle of her fertile years yeah
yeah
there's a little bit wrong and i did
retweet it to try and maybe spark a bit
of debate and
the woman who wrote the tweet anna gatt
i actually really admire her most of her
twitter uh content and she runs a really
cool uh organization called the inter
intellect which puts on kind of
intellectual gather salon type
gatherings so i don't mean to like dunk
on her take and it is interesting on one
level and maybe there is some truth to
it but yeah it's missing that piece of
you know i feel like maybe saying to her
your intrasexual competition is showing
but you know intersexual competition
particularly for women is very hidden
even to themselves yeah so
you can't let it show you can't really
it has to be all uh subtle um
which is interesting so she might not
even actually perceive a lesson hmm yeah
i think that the
the
younger women versus older women thing
is it's a difficult area to get into
right like
especially with the world of red pill at
the moment
age is one of those things that gets
weaponized by the guys that are talking
in that red pill space and never gets
used as a tactic that men should take on
in order to open up their dating
opportunities which just blows my mind
the start at the start of your paper
that you did
about incels you have this quote from
charles darwin who says the power to
charm the female has sometimes been more
important than the power to conquer
other males in battle why was that there
at the beginning
i just wanted to kind of
highlight how important and fundamental
the recurring problem of finding and
retaining a mate has been evolutionarily
like we're an unbroken chain of
ancestors who did just that so that's
incredible you know when whenever i feel
small in the world i kind of think of
that and so it's a big problem it's the
number one kind of problem on people's
minds i wanted to put that front and
center and whenever you have any
evolutionary problem or something like
that or any new problem darwin probably
had a really insightful quote on it or
william james uh they actually had such
an intuitive uh sense of human
psychology which is a it's so
interesting so yeah i wanted to kind of
start it as
this
i wanted to approach the paper from an
evolutionary point of view so that was a
good start and you know those
methods of attracting a mate
you know by beating a man in combat are
really not available to you now like
those
tactics that might have made you an
evolutionary success in attracting a
mate for most of our ancestral history
would now probably land you in jail most
of the time uh so you know we're living
in a very evolutionary mismatched kind
of world um
in terms of our ma or the mating domain
actually
there's an author carrie getz and she
wrote a paper with some some other
uh scholars including my supervisor
david buss about evolutionary mismatch
in mating so evolutionary mismatch is
the idea that the world around us
differs radically from the world in
response to which our
psychological mechanisms evolved and uh
they coined the the acronym strangely
weird so you might have heard of the in
the acronym weird in psychology
industrialized rich and democratic so
like over 90 of psychology studies are
based on weird societies and they house
just like 12 of the world's population
so they built on that so not only is our
mating environment weird but it's also
strangely weird so we have access to
social media and dating apps temporary
relationships relocatable we're
relocatable we can move around
geographically we have way more autonomy
for the inmate choice uh whereas in in
the past you wouldn't have that much
choice anyway and your parents probably
would have decided it for you
we have the ability to remain
nulliperous which means like not having
children by decision that's very
evolutionary novel and we're segmented
by groups uh often find ourselves in
educational settings with concentrated
uh huge amounts of young people we have
lots of options and we're making
decisions as kind of young adults so a
young adult
would have been a seasoned parent by
like 25 so the fact that they're you're
kind of this delayed adolescents almost
being a young adult is pretty
evolutionary novel too
it's interesting to think i imagine that
uh some of the incels that you've
studied
must get pushback from normal people
when they say well look finding a
partner isn't the be-all and end all of
life it's not like you can't go through
life without the lady the
with five houses in new york you know
she's going through life and she's
perfectly happy why is it that you need
and i think that that darwin quote to me
just reminds us especially for men the
fear
the ambient anxiety of not being a
genetic success
hangs heavy
yeah and actually it's like a an under
maybe explored part of in insulting that
it's also it's not just involuntary
celibate and the sex it's involuntarily
childless like becoming a father is one
of the most meaningful things in many
men's lives and that's not on the cards
for themselves as far as they're
concerned that must be very very
psychologically distressing and yeah
when people say that to me of oh it's
not be all and end all it reminds me of
that meme
where it says life is so simple have
problem don't care about problems
it's like why not simply just don't care
about your problems like
what advice is that you know it's like
yeah of course that would be easy if
only i could just not care did you look
at anything like um
opinions around adoption or pets
in the in cell world
i didn't what what ideas do you have on
that like one of the problems you have
with men is that they're childless you
can have a child i'm aware that it's not
precisely your genetic lineage but
people that are adoptee parents seem
pretty happy to me
you know what i did actually include a
question on that of whether you'd like
to become a parent and i even included
options of whether you'd like to
but only if you had a partner or yes i
would like to on my own but i didn't
actually include it in any of the two
papers we're writing but i might
actually look back on that and i'll send
it your way uh to let you know what the
what the attitudes were there i asked a
lot of questions that i didn't actually
even get to report on because i figured
if i've got a lot of incels engaging
with the study i'm going to ask them a
lot of things and get a lot of mileage
out of this study yeah i just wonder i
think a big part of it
i had nama kates on the show i've spoken
to james bloodworth a lot of the
conversations i've had around
the crisis of sort of male dating at the
moment touches on this and the part of
it is that it seems it's the desire for
men to feel like they're wanted they
want to be wanted you know and that
makes them
it it weaves them into the tapestry of
society overall and the less that
they're wanted the more that they pull
themselves away and there's certain
things i walk there's this dog park next
to my house and i walk every single
morning and all of the people that have
got dogs have got friends because the
dogs make friends and i just wondered
whether i don't know pet ownership and
or adoption is something that incels
have potentially considered as a way to
re-weave themselves back in
it's a it's a good point because yeah
also having a dog is very attractive to
women actually maybe did you see
the study that came out about six months
ago that was looking at a man holding a
cat in his tinder photos gets about 30
less swipes than a guy that's got a dog
who gets
versus the norm
versus the control sorry he gets like 20
more yeah i'm not surprised with that um
but and another study at a conference i
attended lately i can't recall who did
it and but they showed that having a dog
indicates uh long-term mating qualities
so women associated a man having a dog
with oh he's reliable he's capable he's
camped down he's obviously not out
partying all the time because he's
looking after the dog you know so it
might be a good tactic you know like
it's kind of tongue-in-cheek or get a
dog in cells will probably get tear
their hair out hearing me saying that
thing oh god how can you minimize the
problems like that but on a on a broader
level of if uh having a girlfriend isn't
on the cards yeah the the kind of
companionship of a pet i i love my dog
he's like my best friend but um
yeah i think that and there was another
study by a scholar called brandon sparks
and he's studying in cells as well and
he found that in cells
they lack
all friends generally not just uh
romantic options they just and they have
that
lacking friends is a kind of a it means
you don't have that buffer against the
negative feelings of not having a
romantic partner you often find that
these single people who are very happy
to be single what they have is very rich
friendships and uh if in cells are
lacking that as well it might be just a
broader loneliness thing which we found
that the
extremely high levels of loneliness
compared to none in cells in our study
what do most in cells have in common
then what about traits and personality
types and whatever what's the
prototypical insole
okay so what we found in terms of
personality they're very
i didn't do this study but they're very
neurotic
kind of high on negative experiences one
thing we found in our study
we tested them for a new scale which is
called the tendency for interpersonal
victimhood and that's a new scale
developed that's comprised of four
different dimensions uh one is the need
for recognition so a very preoccupied
with having the legitimacy of their
grievances acknowledged so the worst
thing you can say to an incel to make
them dr tear their hair out is you don't
have it that bad you're you're not so
bad you know you have to actually
recognize that they are suffering and
actually i think that's why they have a
bit of rapport with me and they seem to
appreciate that i don't sugarcoat it or
gaslight them as they say so they seem
to appreciate i wrote a blog a couple of
years back called step your dick up why
uh advice given to incels um it won't
work and it kind of just laid it out how
insufficient the advice is
is for in cell so one dimension of that
personality trait that victimhood trait
is need for recognition the next is
moral elitism so the belief that the
individual or their in-group behaves
more morally than others and you might
see this within cells kind of
uh sneering at
the superficiality of the mating market
but for both chads and stacy's they
think oh they're all
i'd have much more high-ended kind of
values and there should be rewarding
intellect and personality that i have
rather than just giga chad and his
gorgeous looks right
the third dimension is lack of empathy
so that plays out um well no one cares
about my problems so why should i care
about anyone else's
and then finally the final dimension is
rumination
which is a constant preoccupation with
reliving their perceived
negative experiences so constantly
ruminating on their
bad experiences and this victimhood
mindset leads to an external locus of
control so in cells with their black
pill kind of philosophy believe that
there is nothing they can do to affect
change in their life so they're just
completely not agentic at all um so
that
you know maybe cultivating an internal
locus of control to some degree might be
a pathway uh out of out of that foreign
cells so we also found extremely low uh
levels of well-being so in cells scored
extremely high on depression anxiety
loneliness and really low on
satisfaction with life so not perhaps
not that surprising but to put that into
context for you uh we used the two
scales the phq-9 to measure depression
so that's the scale used by the nhs
in the uk and anxiety we used the gad7
to measure anxiety so in terms of
depression uh roughly 73 percent of in
cells were diagnosed as severely or
moderately severely depressed versus 33
of non-in cells which 33 seemed pretty
high to me anyway but in the general
population but 73 is you know
that's very very high in terms of
anxiety we had 67 percent of in cells
clinically diagnosable as severely or
moderately anxious versus 38
of none in cells and
incels also scored very high on
sociosexual desire so that's the desire
dimension of sociosexuality so they're
very they have a high level of sexual
desire and i thought one of the
hypotheses i had in my um
in my dissertation that it was the only
one that wasn't supported i thought that
for those in cells who have a high level
of sociosexual desire that that would
actually lead to worse levels of
well-being for those because they might
be
if you have high levels of desire but
you're perceiving that you have no way
to act on that desire uh then it's um
that that to me would result in lower
levels of well-being if you didn't have
a high level of desire then it's not
that big of a problem anyway it's like
oh well i can't get the sex i don't
really want anyway so not too bad but
actually it just it
it didn't moderate things uh in any way
but that might be just because in cells
have just low levels of well-being kind
of across the board
their current
mental state is so robustly negative
that there's very little that can push
that down any further what so one of the
one of the interesting things to come
out of that is it seems like incels have
to have a preoccupation with
sociosexuality with wanting a mate with
thinking about a mate because if it
wasn't it simply wouldn't be such a
central part of their life if they were
completely obsessed with warhammer or
with pickleball
or
whatever art or something and something
big happened in the art world and they
were spurned from all of their art
friends that would be the in-cell
equivalent of being kicked out of the
thing that you care about it seems like
most of the incels the thing that they
care about which is one of the most core
parts of their bit perhaps the most core
part of their being is that
sociosexuality absolutely and you can
even like see it in the kind of language
they use it's almost sometimes
homoerotic about chad you know and stacy
and like they draw cartoons with chad's
big dick and it's very like erotic like
they're very charged and kind of
viscerally sexual in their
discourse you know so yeah that's why i
kind of thought and also
can you blame himself i mean we live in
a world that's very saturated with sex
like you see it on billboards and movies
and like you get the impression that
everyone is out there having amazing sex
life we live in a hook-up culture it's
actually not true you know people aren't
having that much sex you know people are
very sexy before
right and you know people overestimate
how much sex other people are having so
uh you know maybe that would be helpful
for himself to realize you know it's not
uh it's not as sex saturated as it might
seem
what about alt-right and being alt-right
there's accusations whenever an incel's
in the press of this is yet another
right-wing misogynist gone wild what did
you find about that yeah so i decided to
measure that it was just one item
question uh on a political affiliation
so i always in the paper i recommend
that we should investigate that a little
bit more but uh
perhaps a surprising finding uh if you
were to go by the mainstream media kind
of discourse we found that a smaller
proportion than would be expected by
chance were white for a majority u.s and
uk uh sample so we had 63
63 and a half percent were white and 36
and a half percent were um
in cells of color and i kind of clumped
all the ethnicities into one so the
inner cells feel about having an incels
of colour movement inside of it
well actually you know what i think it
might be a way to cultivate maybe a bit
more sympathy because in the kind of
oppression olympics world i i listened
to one academic on another podcast and
when she was talking about the insult
problem initially the podcast host was a
bit kind of sneering and he kind of
thought oh this is just a
right wing white male problem but when
she told him oh actually there's a lot
of incels of color he completely changed
tact and he was completely sympathetic
and it was suddenly oh actually you know
there might be something we should have
sympathy here so uh we investigated the
political leanings as well and we found
that 39
reported to be right-leaning 45
reported to be left-leaning and roughly
17 reported to be centrist so not what
you'd expect to find a counter-intuitive
finding in our data um but perhaps not
that surprising if you think about a lot
of in-cell discourses about kind of
egalitarian more redistribution of
sexual access and equality and they're
very concerned with the racism of the
mating market so it would be very
surprising for me
to find uh you know a large white
supremacist or right-wing
presence but you know there is a lot of
racialized derogatory slang in the
encelosphere some of their language is
very you know unsavory but they all
their language is unsavory that's their
thing
that's wrong when you put a lot of men
in any situation together for a long
time and especially if you drive that
conversation completely underground and
say you're your own underground society
you're not attached to real society so
they're going to play by their own
dispense with the precisely i'll
dispense the norms of society i don't
need to play by your rules so and it
might be a way of lashing out at society
of oh well at least here you can't
control us we can't we don't have to
play by your rules in our world put
performative ruthlessness with the
language
absolutely so another study found
it analyzed in cell forum posts and it
found that just three percent of incel
posts could be considered racist uh
meanwhile 30 of in cell threads could be
considered misogynistic the same study
found but again that to me seems a
little bit low you would think from the
discourse about in cells that it would
be higher than that and it would be like
100
right yeah so and she the the author
found that self-hatred is by far the
most common form of toxic language in
the enceladosphere uh so yeah that was
uh our findings on the ethnicity and
political affiliation most of the
distaste from in cells is directed at
themselves
oh absolutely yeah and uh so i'm often
asked to look at inseldom from an
extremism point of view which kind of
makes sense you know a lot of maybe
alarmism or concern about maybe the new
terrorist threat and i think that's a
little bit inflated given that the
worldwide death toll attributable to
insult violence is roughly 60 and you
know compared to other forms of
terrorism that could be considered just
a bad day in afghanistan or something
you know 60 is pretty low and i don't
mean to demean any of the violence or
people who've lost their lives but 10 of
those deaths are directly attributable
to alec manasian who who recently was
sentenced to 25 years to life he's the
the guy who in 2014 drove his car into
the crowd of people in toronto killing
10 people so 10 out of the 60 are
directly attributable to him alone and
he's the guy who wrote the facebook post
before he did what he did saying all
hail the supreme gentleman elliot roger
we will spark the insult rebellion has
already begun uh that we will overthrow
the chads and the staceys now he is
always held up front and center as the
poster boy of incel movement and
violence
what's less often reported in the media
is in the judge's verdict on alec
mnasian
i'll read directly to you from that
verdict he told lies deliberately to
depict the killings as being connected
to the incel movement and get more media
attention he piggybacked on the insult
movement to ratchet up his own notoriety
his story to the police about the attack
being an incel rebellion was a lie
so you never hear that reported and and
then another example of the media maybe
being um
having a you know
been irresponsible perhaps on the insult
topic is the the jake davison which is
the first alleged incel attack in the uk
in plymouth in 2021
um where he killed five people including
his mother and a three-year-old girl
before killing himself and
he's kind of you know there's a lot of
concern about how he's emblematic of the
in-cell violence but you very rarely
hear it reported that the deputy senior
national coordinator for uk
counter-terrorism policing
tim jock is his name concluded that jake
davidson was not motivated by the
misogynistic insult online movement the
shooting was not terror related and the
incel ideology is not a terrorist
movement so you know it's a perhaps a
bit alarmist and i think the media is a
little bit irresponsible uh i think they
should like with school shooters or like
with any kind of lone wolf attacker they
should incorporate a no notoriety
protocol that's actually in the
guidelines from the institute for
research on male supremacism they have a
document of recommendations for media
reporting on in-cell violence and it's
actually pretty even-handed i thought
with them
an organization title
about male supremacism i thought it
would be a bit more alarmist but i think
it's pretty reasonable especially that
bit uh but i i do think it's very
strange to categorize incels as male
supremacists because their whole
identity is based around highlighting
their own ineptitude so it's um it's a
little bit strange yeah it would be a
very ineffective way to try and
uh get other people to be in cells as
well it doesn't seem to me like they're
co-opting other people into this
movement they've very much siloed
themselves away you think about most of
the terrorist organizations one of the
primary things that they're trying to do
is to recruit more members of that cult
or religion or ideology yes and even
just from if we think more logistically
from a terrorism point of view
organizing a terrorist attack is a
logistical has to be a smooth operation
right you have to have a well-organized
group of people who have coherent goals
agree on collective actions towards
those goals and agree that maybe
violence is the the pathway forward uh
incels don't seem to fit that mold for
me and i liken it to the new batman film
have you seen the new batman film with
the riddler i have
yeah so spoiler alert for anybody who
hasn't watched the movie yet but
basically
the story line is that the riddler
essentially mobilizes what's kind of
hinted at as like an army of
disenfranchised young men maybe
basically in-cells who kind of
collectively mobilize online and then
meet
in person the first time to organize
this amazingly sophisticated terror
attacks on gotham city that sounds like
a nightmare to organize if you've got a
group of people who have never as far as
we know incels don't meet uh offline i
saw
in
the most recent article shared by uh
alex state psych he was talking about
only
most most only three percent of incel
dot is forum members speak to each other
like that they basically do not connect
with any of the other members in there
that even within their own silo within
their own community they're still
unbelievably isolated within that yeah
it's it's just like a kind of a
screaming into the void almost and the
connection maybe comes from seeing what
others express and that might be enough
rather than actual social connection um
but yeah another finding from i think
it's the same study that alex posted but
it shows that the vast majority of the
extreme uh online hatred or hostility is
produced by just 10
of in cell accounts so you know we tend
to with any other group we tend to
have the
the kind of philosophy that we don't
judge them by the most extreme actions
of a minority within that group we don't
categorize muslims as terrorists because
of the actions of an extreme minority
but we do that within cells readily
we're happy
to let the minority speak loudly for for
the whole community um but yeah i don't
think it's as coherently organized
as perhaps the
the media kind of
suggests but you mentioned a bit there
earlier that they don't seem to want to
attract in cells in and i i agree that
they don't seem to want to attract in
cells
to join or anything like uh
anything like a grooming kind of uh
strategy but once in cells are in i
think they very much want to keep them
in there and it's actually very limiting
for an incel who wants to ascend to
maybe you know engage with the mating
market again because the other incels in
the forums might even kick you out of
the forum if you talk about trying to
get a date or even going on a date
so they'll say oh you're a fake cell and
what were you doing here i only just
learned the term fake cell off another
one of alex's posts what's what's that
what's the issue
within the
in-cell community of fake cells of
ascending and of giving hope
so yeah so they i think it's like
basically it's a slap in the face to
their world view to see somebody ascend
and you know there's not a wholesale
agreement on this i'd say a lot of
incels are kind of limiting to others
and want to keep them dragged down alone
together that's the kind of the
attitude whereas other incels might
actually be
encouraging and want to see other
in-cells succeed certainly in the
qualitative interviews i've done
one-to-one with themselves i i've met
some of those guys who actually want to
see others succeed and who haven't given
up um but yeah it's a very limiting
because at first when i started to study
incels i thought how could anyone kind
of come to identify with this aspect
surely if you felt that way about
yourself you'd want to keep that hidden
you wouldn't hunker down into that
identity but as i began to study it more
they actually get a lot out of their
in-cell identity
compared to the anxiety-inducing mating
market they get
a sense of belonging fraternity a
virtuous victimhood identity which is
very very in vogue these days so they're
like oh i'll have a piece of that
victimhood pie please and
yeah there's one study that shows that
incels report their reasons for using
forums are to feel understood feel less
lonely and get a sense of belonging um
but in that study a little over half of
the participants reported that the forum
made them feel hopeless so it's very
very much a mixed bag and in my study i
decided to break it down i managed to
recruit 151 in cells and a lot of them
were non-forum using which i think is
really good data because it shows you
that the intel phenomenon is a little
bit more than just an online subculture
but one of the useful things there was i
was able to compare forum using versus
non-forum using incels and forum use
slightly predicted greater anxiety
37
uh of uh
in cells who use the forum said that it
made their well-being much or somewhat
better while 39 were not sure and 24
thought that it worsened their
well-being so it's very much a mixed bag
that for some the forums might be great
it's finally i've found some
camaraderie and for others it might be
really really limiting and worsening
their their mental health
only 20
of in cells in my study
indicated that they do not believe they
will be involuntarily celibate for the
rest of their life and this belief in
permanency of inseldom was a significant
predictor of depression and low life
satisfaction so
it does seem in our data on the actual
mental health outcomes that believing in
the black pill seems to be a big
predictor of depression and low life
satisfaction but uh that's quite high
that eighty percent of the incels in my
study think they will be in cell for
life it's not it's not going to change
that's one of the predictors for people
that take their own lives as well right
that this is bad it's not going to get
better and this is the way that it's
always going to be
yes and that ties in with the no the no
internal locus of control it's like i
can't change nothing will change it my
life is completely at the forces of
everything outside of me and you know
suicidality
is quite high among in cells too
eighty-two percent of in cells indicated
that they had strongly considered
committing suicide and there's one
minute
82
82
um dude that's the most shocking
statistic that i've heard so far yeah
that's why now that is from an in-house
uh survey but there's another really
good qualitative kind of or a
linguistic analysis uh study uh by dr
sarah daley let me get the name of it oh
it says goodbye my friend cells and it
analyzes forum content uh of basically
what appeared to be like suicide notes
from incel saying like this is it um you
won't hear from me again after that and
um
you know that's quite kind of harrowing
to think about that and you could maybe
analyze that further and say did this
account ever post again if not you can
kind of maybe have a conclusion
a really sad case um
for me a couple of years ago was an
insult who
he he he um it has a somewhat happy
ending this story but i was very worried
for a while and
an incel who like engages in back and
forth with me on twitter and with
several others um
pretty kind of good-natured guy i don't
know who he really is in real life
anonymous kind of account but he
basically tweeted out a picture of a
bullet and said goodbye and then no one
had heard from him for months and months
and months and months and months but he
did resurface and he's back he's back
with us but he often quite darkly hints
at
suicidality
intel's have quite gallows humor as well
but uh yeah it's a pose law kind of
running rampant here yeah
yeah but i think so from extremism point
of view and i'm asked about incels from
extremism i think about it what does
extreme insult them look like and to me
it looks more like suicidality than
terrorism and even like most of the in
cell attacks because most of the focus
of the in cells is on hatred of the self
not on an outward based
yeah so you'd be much more likely to get
to drink the kool-aid situation than you
would be to get a terrorist attack yes
and if you are to get a like a terrorist
attack or a lone wolf lashing out at
society it's kind of suicidal in itself
you know like
all of them pretty much know they're
going to either die by cop or
kill themselves in the process but one
thing that's also very interesting from
the
actual even the in-cell attacks they've
just been more like a lashing out at
society in general rather than a
specific targeting okay elliot roger did
try to specifically target uh women but
the rest have just seemed to have like a
break from reality and kind of just
attack everyone and there's been a
distinct lack of sexual violence uh they
don't like rape alongside their violence
which is uh interesting and um you know
the the rape um the hypothesis of rape
as a mate-deprived
strategy so make deprived men uh are one
once we were hypothesizing that make
deprived men would rape more but it's
actually not true the most rapists are
narcissistic sexually successful men who
think they're the ones who actually have
the sexual entitlement you know incels
are always talked about having sexual
entitlement and having just two high
standards that's something we measured
in my dissertation and we're working on
that paper now is analyzing whether this
was true whether they had just simply
too high made preferences compared to
none in cells but they didn't they had
significantly lower mate preferences on
every metric and overall and
evolutionarily that would make sense
because
it wouldn't make sense as a strategy uh
in in the
ancestral environment for low mate value
men to concentrate their finite mating
effort on competing with high value men
for high value women it's just not a
good tactic
so it didn't surprise me at all that
that wasn't really true about in cells
and you know it's in in evolutionary
psychology we call that adaptive
self-assessment so you actually like
lower your standards if you feel like
okay well what am i what can i actually
realistically attract
we also found then we analyzed their
perceptions of female mate preferences
and we found that they overestimated the
importance of
physical attractiveness and financial
prospects and underestimated the
importance of intelligence kindness and
humor
but we also found that the ordinary men
or the the the non-incel men in our
study made the same mistakes and there's
a lot going on here because
you know you have social desirability
bias
in studies whereby
women might actually you know under
report how much they value physical
attractiveness or financial resources
because they have robust data that they
do actually value those but there is
robust data to show that they do value
the personality traits too so i think in
cells might not they might be not as
wrong in overestimating the importance
of finance and attractiveness but i
think they are wrong in underestimating
the rest of the stuff too
looks money status lms right right
that's the order and i learned this from
nama and
i said well hang on is that the order
that it goes in looks money status yes
yeah that's what it's going to be but it
didn't make sense to me until you
realize that for many of the guys that
are in the in cell forums they are
people that are autistic they're a
significantly high proportion of people
with disabilities significantly high
proportion of people that are from
on average less desirable ethnic
backgrounds as well
um you know when you bundle all of these
things together it
it does make a little bit more sense
about why they would because the looks
is just to them it is a hurdle that
cannot be gotten past so yes thinking
about this
how much is the current in-cell
phenomenon being driven by a
state-of-seeking online world the
instagrams and then also the online
dating with regards to the tinder in
your view
yeah i mean so that's like online dating
is a evolutionary novel ubiquitous
feature of the modern mating market now
and it essentially opens you up to the
world's biggest status game so you feel
like you're competing with
you know chad like and you know leonardo
dicaprio now that you're single right
yeah on one level you kind of are you
know women can open their mating pool
they can extend their radius to the next
city they don't have to limit themselves
if you think evolutionarily we might
have encountered perhaps a couple of
dozen potential mates in our lifetime so
persistent rejection would have been
perceived as catastrophic you know if
you you can rack up more rejection on
tinder now in one afternoon than would
have been possible in a lifetime
ancestrally so we're kind of maybe wired
to perceive rejection as really
catastrophic even though in reality it
doesn't need to be in realistically we
should be saying oh there's literally
thousands of more fish in the sea
millions you know they'll just go again
but it doesn't it hurts like rejection
hurts and that's because
most of the time it was like a a
downward spiral and if one or two
rejected you you had a reputation they
told all the other girls oh it's
disaster you know so maybe themselves
are kind of sensitive to that
it is interesting thinking about how
much more state seeking the world's
become the fact that you have objective
metrics of status basically with ticks
and follow accounts and likes and stuff
like that
it doesn't surprise me that
looks
and status and money
are being seen as something especially
by people that spend a lot of time
online and don't get to stress test this
in the real world that you know i've got
friends at home that are not lookers not
rich not that smart but they are funny
as hell and they will make everybody in
a group laugh never had a problem with
girls never despite from outwardly
looking like someone that you know
probably is on the cusp of insulting but
you know whatever fifa points that
person got all of them got taken from
good looks and pumped into 100 max stats
but i mean they even have what's it
called clown maxing what's that
yeah anything maxing is just kind of
zeroing in on putting all your effort
into that domain and trying to improve
and i do agree with you that you don't
really have any choice but to compensate
i always make the joke that i compensate
with for my height being five foot seven
with a nice charming irish accent so
that seems to work for me um but you
know cultivating a winning personality
is not that easy you know it's not that
easy to just say oh yeah
you don't look that great but just
compensate with a brilliant personality
just be really funny you know and if
you're autistic if you're um
anxious that's really difficult and if
you're getting rejected a lot it's it
and we have the halo effect that we tend
to perceive people who are attractive as
having more winning personalities anyway
so there's a whole lot going on there
but yeah i tend to agree with you that
you know my kind of intuitive attitude
and i'd never really
i think each in insult individually has
to take case-by-case scenario it's not
obvious to me that engaging with the
major market is the best thing to do at
all times for every incel i think it's a
case-by-case scenario but my intuitive
reaction is yeah put in the effort do do
focus on self-improvement you know
and there's studies to show that what
women find attractive in um
in men
is more malleable you can actually put
effort into that you can make more money
you can get more stages you can
you can even improve your looks perhaps
more um the only one whereas women
physical attractiveness is either there
or it isn't and certainly age once it's
kind of gone it's gone kind of thing uh
for women so that's a bit of an
imbalance there but the only exception
is height and i know people are going to
criticize me for being concerned about
that one but it is true there's not
really much you can do to change your
height and it seems to be a really
significant one for women uh you you had
um logan yuri on the relationship
science director at hinge and she talked
about how much if women
set their height parameters on a dating
app to over six foot it limits their
dating pool to was it 30
85 of people don't 85 of men don't meet
that criteria whoa that's even more than
i thought wow so you're just stripping
back your mating pool
in one fell swoop and secondly then if
it's over six foot three i think it's
just three percent of men will meet that
criteria in america so yeah really bad
and when you think about sex ratios if
you have a minority in any sex ratio
they call the shots in terms of
sociosexuality the whole guy is having a
great time on hinge right so
men are like
more reluctant to commit to long-term
mating and you know you've seen the
statistics on uh
you know the sexlessness that the
compare
men younger than 30 reporting having no
sex in the last year rose from eight
percent to into 2008 to 28 in 2018. but
there's another study that also showed
that compared to 2002 men overall had
the same number of partners in 2013. but
the top 20 of men had a 25
increase in sexual partners and the top
5 percent of men had an even more
dramatic 38 increase so it really is
that kind of effective polygony towards
the top where uh yeah the minority of
men that the chads are actually cleaning
up
in some data but we've always had
variable mating success amongst men
right
i think ancestrally 40 percent of men
had children and 60 didn't eight around
about 80 percent of women did and 20
didn't so this challenge of
having difficulty in finding a mate
doesn't seem to be particularly novel
no it's always been we've always had
kind of incels but maybe they didn't
collectively organize or find each other
and identify with this aspect of their
personality you also had maybe more kind
of uh medieval type institutions or
ancient institutions to deal with this
surplus of young men
so
even war sending them raiding and
pillaging as vikings vikings would be an
example of maybe what you would do with
your surplus male population you'd send
them raiding uh mary harrington who i
believe you've had on the show as well
she wrote a cool article for unheard
about incels as the new vikings because
we no longer have
making vikings out of them or sending
them to the monastery as an option to
deal with this surplus population of
unpartnered young men but we do seem to
have the internet and that seems to be
kind of the the pacifier that
that they're locking into that world
what was that study that you looked at
that discovered the likelihood of incels
arising geographically
right yeah so this was a really cool
study that the authors rob brooks and
candace blake and they were kind enough
to share it with me
in advance of it being published so i
could reference it in my dissertation
because it provided like a lot of
empirical support for my theoretical
ideas about this mating crisis uh and
they basically found that in cells are
kind of partially accurate about what's
causing their crisis so they could
actually
predict geographic areas of high online
in-cell activity by three variables high
levels of income inequality overall
low gender pay gaps because gender pay
gaps actually alleviate mating market
competition for both sexes because if
women are earning more they're limiting
their pool and they're also competing
with more because men don't tend to care
about socioeconomic status that much or
not as much as as women so it's like it
really narrows their pool and the third
variable was male biased sex ratios so
in geographic areas where there are
fewer single women more in cells so it
you know sexual behavior and even
in-cell identity is sensitive to the
local amazing ecology uh so we can maybe
predict areas of more
that might be more this might be more
concerning
that's interesting um yeah there's a
good cool way to do a study yeah
i
it's also interesting
that
despite the fact that intel spend most
of their time online in the
proliferation of online dating
that
local ecology still plays such a big
role that we are still very much a you
know geographically bound creature that
is reliant on who we see in
college or who we see at the
coffee shop or whatever yeah you don't
know how that algorithm is getting the
cues and what it's what it's doing in
there you know like we have some like
sociometer it's kind of called you
you're monitoring your own mate value
all the time and that's kind of cue to
your your self-esteem but yeah you must
be monitoring the sex ratio and i am
always interested in that in how do we
actually form our model of the sex ratio
because
even if i find myself living in one of
those big cities with loads of single
women
that shouldn't matter to me if i never
go outside or if i you know precisely it
seems to you know it
if you occupy that domain it seems to
you do pick up on the cue you know the
extra sensory perception rupert
sheldrake's morphic resonance or
whatever you're just detecting that
there's more women around yeah it is i
mean the sex ratio hypothesis to me just
makes so much sense it's one of those
red pills that once you see you can't
unsee it right and yeah i mean
combining all of this together
is a a pretty scary situation i think
generally uh on a number of different
levels so
personally for individual people on
average it's going to be harder for
women to find a partner that they're
attracted to and for men to find a
partner that's attracted to them
it's got implications for population
collapse and population size replacement
rates replacement levels and stuff like
that uh it's psychologically
not having a partner not having a family
not having that support structure is
going to make more people feel lonely in
a world where the median or the most
common answer to the question of how
many friends close friends do you have
that you could ring in an emergency is
zero it's the most common answer it's
not the average it's also not the the
median but it's the most common answer
was zero um
all of this combined together
the mating crisis is real man you know
it is
and it's real in a way
that doesn't galvanize people the same
as seeing forest fires or uh depreciated
coral reef beds and stuff this is the
same the reason um mike
solana writes about uh population
collapse as being a creeping existential
risk it just doesn't galvanize people in
the same way it's not it's not this big
thing that you can go on about it's
something that creeps up on you step by
step day by day and then
what is it demography is destiny
that that locks it you can't but you
cannot give birth to any more
five-year-olds now you can only give
birth to naughty year-olds yeah you had
a very frightening uh podcast episode
with with peter taylor
zion yeah
yeah that was a bleak but uh yeah it's
amazing crisis is real man absolutely
and uh it's a project uh that david boss
uh my supervisor and i and a couple of
other scholars are actually working on
writing a paper on now um including
candice blake who i mentioned in that
previous in-cell study and so we're
going to
do one of the first academic studies on
this because it's got a lot of attention
in maybe like pop science articles a
couple of cooled articles about
attraction inequality and things like
that i think it is cause for concern and
like you said we're going to look at it
from all those different lenses and say
what are the potential implications of
this you know my supervisor david boss
he wrote a blog about this in 2016
applying the mating crisis
of higher educated women just
specifically to ut here to the
university of texas at austin um but
that like he was way ahead of the curve
there and we're finally getting around
to maybe dig into that project um but
yeah he he kind of saw it coming
it's it's serious stuff and
it's one of the reasons that i
understand why
i understand why it causes especially
the guys in the red pill world to feel
virtuously or justly
energized around this topic because up
until the point of which you start
seeing women as the adversary there are
a lot of kernels of truth in the things
that they're talking about like look
this is dangerous this is going to make
people unhappy this male default that is
being presupposed as the uh optimal
strategy that all
sexes should aim for like
it is
something that needs to be taken more
seriously and then when you see flippant
replies online
about stuff like motherhood is just a
learned societal construct or you can go
and enjoy your life like the most
important thing your new louis vuitton
shoes and your handbags to impress the
people that you don't give a [ __ ] about
i i think that's one of the reasons why
it does get to me when i read that stuff
online because i realize that it's
driving us closer and closer faster and
faster toward a future
which i don't think is very good and we
don't need help getting there everybody
is self-generating this distance lonely
atomized
unable to have sex existence we do not
need the elite media classes who all
have four kids
to tell us that you don't need kids to
be happy and that you shouldn't focus on
finding love and how you should have sex
without catching fields here's five ways
that you can not text him back the next
day
[ __ ] you yeah yeah no it's bleak um and
you know
one thing i try and highlight is that i
picked the incel topic because it's just
a symptom of this broader mating crisis
so i want to like expand my kind of a
scholarly work to look at the mating
crisis more broadly and one key feature
is that the mating crisis hurts
everybody not just in cells not just men
it hurts everybody almost everybody
except a tiny minority of men at the top
right and arguably maybe them too
because it you know it's maybe not the
most fulfilling life to just a
short-term mate in perpetuity i don't
know leo seems pretty happy but i don't
know um but yeah it's a amazing crisis
and its consequences certainly uh hurt
everybody but i suppose
it's hard to galvanize
cultural consciousness of support for
sorting it out because there are no
clear solutions really uh other than
awareness i suppose um and also the
causes of it are arguably
some of the net wins of feminism right
so women's liberation into the workplace
that's a tough beast to beat what do you
want to do you want to rip women back
out they only just managed to get pay
pay equality and you're gonna go well
what's happening here is it is reducing
down your pool of men that you can
hypergamously date up and across you are
going to be left an alpha widow have you
considered
being a checkout assistant for the
remainder of your days and not ever
applying for a promotion because
you might find yourself happier in
dating
uh yeah dude it's it's no one's gonna no
one's gonna accept that regression yeah
jordan peterson actually even talks
about it when he was asked he said why
does your message appeal to men so much
and he said well it should appeal
to women too and said why what you're
speaking mainly to men he said well what
kind of partners do you want do you want
capable competent partners that should
concern you you know
get them to clean the room but you see
even in the public uh articles about
this they're beginning to write about it
a little bit more and some of the
headlines are as
like on the nose as broke men are
hurting american women's marriage
prospects and it really like brings the
hypergamy kind of uh front and center
with almost inadvertently and there was
a recent psychology today one that
talked about how due to increasing
standards for relationships men just
aren't measuring up and they need to
work on their relationship skills and i
was kind of thinking yeah relationship
skills yeah
come on that was a very uncharitable
piece i thought but it did kind of talk
about that people are beginning to maybe
recognize this mating crisis but um
their framing of it can be very very uh
different depending on your perspective
william costello ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do i love your twitter
account they need to go and follow you
on twitter the stuff that you share if
you're into this is phenomenal why
should they uh harass you on the
internet well twitter is probably my the
main place i spend far too much time on
there probably like a lot of academics
but
but uh for better or for worse but uh my
handle is at costello william and uh
yeah we'll post our studies there and uh
anything interesting that i can see
william thank
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
you